hello
hello hello hello hello
srianth pharma hello you were first
what's going on everybody
what did everybody think of the
spider-man nelly home trailer i want to
know everybody's thoughts right now
did my notification not go out
did y'all get my notification i didn't
get it
what is up what is up what is up
hello hello hello woof
when will another trailer for spider-man
no way home come out
probably like in two months i would
probably say that's probably where we're
at right now
but venom two
then two just got delayed
which is not good
that's not a good sign not a good sign
did you get i think i just got my there
we go there's notification let's check
the sound settings real quick
everything looks good
i'm doing good i'm uh i'm very tired
it's been a very hectic uh past two days
waiting for this trailer uh
i don't i don't think you guys
understand how much it stresses us out
when we like know something is coming
but like sources are like oh yeah it's
like coming within this time frame and
they don't have like an exact time for
us um
it gets
it gets a little crazy so like right now
i'm not operating on much sleep and
tomorrow i have to i don't have to i get
to interview fala chen
she's from chiang chi she's she plays
shang chi's mother
and she's like an award-winning actress
in china and asia
and so i get to get to interview her
tomorrow in the morning so
i i have to uh
i have to kind of get off right after
what if and
sleep because i gotta i gotta i gotta
take a
i gotta get sleeper i'm gonna look like
crap in the interview
so all right yeah it's looking like
venom is gonna get delayed
um
i don't know what that means for
spider-man i'm gonna assume
that it's gonna be delayed as well which
is you know not what we want but
yeah
yeah yeah what is latest contract
between
sony and marvel
uh from what i hear yeah they're they're
doing really really well
um
and all is well
i think uh they're gonna continue to uh
i think they're gonna continue to
play nice i think it just makes sense
for both parties i i especially think so
after spider-man no way home
i really do think it's gonna just be an
insane movie like
and i i question like what it's like
during covid times and it's also really
hot in here so i want to take my jacket
off but like i question what kovid's
going to do to it because i truly think
like
this so has the potential to be one of
the biggest movies of all time
and i think if kovid wasn't a thing and
the theaters weren't you know
like if they weren't at if they were at
full capacity no one was afraid to go to
theaters and you know everybody was kind
of back i i think
i don't think it would have a problem
crushing records like i really don't
think like i think it could probably
beat avengers in game like
i don't think it would have a problem
doing that i really don't
so
i'm
i'm wanting it to beat
i'm wanting it to beat
all the records from before
guys i i think it's doctor strange um
there's some good theories i'm gonna go
over but i see some people talking about
talking about
who is dr strange doesn't kind of seem
like him
um i i think it might be him um you
never really know what being dead for
five years does to somebody um and i
wonder in multiverse of madness if
they're going to tell us if doctor
strange is going to kind of be like
oh we were dead for five years this is
where we were right because he's
master mystic arts
were they somewhere where is the was the
soul world a thing right like in the
comics uh
who knows there's a lot that multiverse
of madness i think can tell us
uh
[Music]
mephisto confirmed harris of one
i have mephisto theories up the butt
rest assure
but i
i
i don't think it's mephisto
it works like the one moment in time
story the one more day story like those
two storylines which they do could like
connect to each other they work where
you know it is mephisto
and him and mj make uh uh well i say him
as in peter parker and mj make a deal
with mephisto to save on may um
that
we definitely get those vibes definitely
definitely get those vibes but
um
i think it's i don't i don't think i
think it's more like the one more time
storyline where strange
iron man and reed richards like they do
what everything and i i don't think it's
prophesto in disguise i i think it's him
i think there's something different
but i think that may come along with
just character development
because now he's
it seems like he is more in charge than
wong
right so maybe just because he's the big
man on campus now and doctor strange has
always been cocky right like you have to
understand that doctor strange has
always been cocky
so maybe that's just what we're seeing
again right he's a little bit more
mastered in the mystic arts now infinity
shades always come in uh always coming
in clutch
with the super chats good eye you might
your hair is looking pretty awesome
thank you it was silver now it's gray
due to all the stress that's spider-man
no way home trailer brought me uh you're
in lockdown in australia
oh dang well y'all have been in lockdown
right like new zealand and australia
y'all didn't like let anybody in or out
right was was that not the case i think
i heard that somewhere i could be wrong
yeah i i think toby is going to take
like the father figure um
and yeah i am going to do some mephisto
talks because obviously those those are
going crazy
um
could it be mordo disguised as doctor
strange i don't think in spider-man i
don't think so i think in multiverse
madness mordo's definitely coming and
that's going to be you know that's going
to be like the big thing but but i i
don't think so i i think it's strange i
i really do think it's doctor strange
all right so
where are we at right now
all right that's all looking good
did venom actually get delayed i haven't
heard from an official source but it's
looking like it is
can i tell the basic plot of this
episode without spoilers uh avengers
loki
uh
what if it went in a completely
different direction than the first
avengers
assembling together
uh
there you go
without spoiling i i uh
uh
i really can't
i really can't say more than that
without support which episode is supreme
spider-man and what if i actually don't
know because i've only seen the first
three episodes
my left monitor went
dark
there we go it's back
who do i think will be the sixth
sinister six
villain
i am really
really wanting to see mysterio
um
i think it's totally like it's such a
mysterio thing
to like fake your death in such an epic
way like he's the master of illusions
right that's
that's what the name of what if earth
law what if earth lost its mightiest
heroes
is that the actual name i don't actually
remember
i can check in my email real fast
actually maybe not uh let me see
i can tell y'all
yeah let me dig into my
[Music]
screener
what
what if episode three
let's see what it's called
i don't uh
it doesn't say what it's called on my
end it just says what if season one
episode three
screener
but that title would be accurate i will
give you that
that title would be accurate
like i said without spoilers it's pretty
much what if it what what if the
assembly of the avengers
in the first avengers film went like was
wrong went wrong
what am i doing
so yeah that's what uh that's what it's
about i don't want to give too much away
uh for those asking what time it's
coming out i would probably say like 10
minutes now uh 15 minutes probably
how did you how do you read all these
messages um i don't it's gonna be
perfectly honest i read as much as i can
um
and i obviously can't answer all of them
because that would just be non-stop
answering just a ton of questions i try
to read all of them as much as i can i
really do
what's the latest contract i think i
already answered that with sony and
marvel i think everything's uh pretty
good
uh
do you think steve is alive and what if
because they have
piggy's blood you mean peggy's blood
logan
um
i think it's just the reverse i think
steve's alive
but he's old and you know he's the one
dying on the hospital bed and showing
pictures of the kids and everything like
that so instead of it being peggy it's
him
do you think deadpool can't will come
out and avengers
uh five i hope comes out before then
and i hope he is with them yes max
conrad what's up
coming in with the super chat thank you
so much
will it be tony starks today he is in
this one
get him mr anderson
mr anderson will ban anyone who he deems
fit he is the moderator he has that
power
so i know some people like they'll tweet
at me or something like that saying i
got banned if if mr anderson
if you do enough for mr anderson to
decide to ban you that's that's the
ultimate decision
uh i trust his judgment
and give it up for him been an awesome
mod for a really long time now
what we're in august yeah
i think probably like six months now
hey thanks gavin appreciate that
it's out j er yeah jaden says it's out
i don't see it out
well spidey oh hey marine how's it going
i think i know we talked today on uh
on uh the real rejects
uh the real rejects
live stream and thank you so much for
the super chat so
grab some one million views marvel
cooler do you uh thank you so much it's
so funny because like
um
like with that video like the update
video that i did right before the
trailer come out that got a million
views i was like
i woke up and it was like doing so what
i was like it's kind of funny because
you know there's a lot of videos like
for example the breakdown that i put so
much like time into
and like i really sit there and like
work really hard on it
and it's just funny that it's just kind
of like i do a video that's kind of like
here's all i've heard like here's my
sources here's what the the insiders are
seeing on twitter like of course that's
the one that gets like a million views
right but hey i'm zero complaints from
me like i'll always take a million views
so thank you so much chicken bird 893
thanks for super chat haven't seen free
guy yes i actually saw it i saw the
screener for that as well i saw it a
couple weeks before it came out
absolutely loved it um
fantastic movie
uh hey jf what's up man how's it going
um
oh there's a bot yeah mr anderson i know
that yeah uh free guy was
is one of my favorite movies now like
it's such a good movie
i really like that movie i love that
movie and i i can never get enough of
ryan reynolds that guys
i could never get enough of ryan
reynolds man
hello
shashank you were thinking that marina
hey srianth varma thank you i appreciate
that enteric r when does it start uh
i give another 10 minutes uh yeah free
guy is a great movie the free guy is a
fantastic movie
and i
yeah i think it's awesome
uh brandon just saw matrix resurrection
trailer yeah i know i'm waiting for them
to release at the public i also want to
see the batman footage that they
released to the public i'm definitely
going to cover
cover that because
batman's my favorite superhero like
as you can see my
my i got a bunch of posters i don't know
if you guys can see but i got some sick
uh
scarlet witch
that's a loki one
they're they're really really sick um
super super cool they're from disc plate
they're like these uh metal metal
posters and they're gonna be in a video
soon because they sent me a bunch and
um
they're just super super cool
the nuts of ryan reynolds he's pretty
good uh free guy better than shang chi
that's like a completely different film
um and i'm sure some people will say
shang chi's better i'm sure some people
will think free guys better to me i
don't even like classify them in
anywhere near the same category i don't
think you can really compare them um
i think like chongqi is an epic film
like like i'm using the term epic in the
actual sense that it's supposed to be
used um not like be like no it's epic
but like it's an epic film
and free guy is a comedy
but free guy will surprise you because
it actually has a lot of emotion in it
it's actually like
it hits you on different levels it's
kind of cool it's a good movie i highly
recommend free guy like
i highly recommend free guy and i
i i seriously love shang chi like i
loved shang chi um
i was partially raised by a korean
family
for almost half my life i think until i
was like
13 14 years old
um
and i did literally martial arts
with
the two sons of the family they were my
best friends growing up and it's like so
cool for them
but it's still so cool for me granted
i'm not asian but i was kind of raised
in a korean culture for a little bit and
it's just really cool
and even if you put that away it's a
great stand-alone movie and a great
standalone mcu movie like really it's
it blew my mind
it has a lot to say about existence and
what makes a life alive i think we're
talking about free guy now mr anderson i
kind of missed some of the chat
my camera is here my chat's here so i
like try to
look in the camera a lot
so i can miss i missed some of the chat
um
who is my favorite minty rebata who's my
favorite marvel character thor
thor okay it's out people
it's out it's out it's out are we ready
we're going to start it let's do the
countdown five
four
three
two
one
clicked it
let's get it going up on the screen
where is there we go
and i don't skip the intro i'm gonna
leave it no that way we can all
watch it in its glory together i gotta
be careful
i gotta be careful with showing some of
the footage because uh
i am getting hit sometimes with the
copyrights for it
so forgive me if i don't show as much
footage as i typically do i think a lot
of people are going to really like this
episode i can't tell if i like the
t'challa one or this one more
but it's a really good episode so let's
go
time
i always feel like it's like for the
older people in here
i always feel like this is like the star
trek opening
space the final frontier
that's like what it always feels like to
me
33 minutes long i can't put the idea to
you guys that's
like y'all know it's illegal right for
me to stream the series like i can't do
that
uh art [ __ ] i don't have my own
i mean i guess i do have my own disney
plus people but being press for disney
it's like what i am for people who ask
me like how do you say everything ahead
of time i'm official press for disney
that's why i was at the red carpet
shanghai that's why i get all these
things uh ahead of time so it's not that
i like have a disney plus guy i'm just
i'm pressed for disney so they sent me
the first three episodes before it came
out
called drinks ready i got my g fuel use
code cosmic if you drink g field
oh yeah yeah i forgot to do this
there was an idea
black whale
uh episode name
i got tony stark right here
what if the world lost the mightiest
heroes
what will i do when i hit a million
party
um i sound different than my videos
because
it's a different mic this is a mic i use
for my videos and this is the mic i use
for
streams
so check this out this is where things
get crazy
she stabs him with the
lithium dioxide
check this out this crazy
boom
he died
what if
yes it is worth to go to this theater
for shangchi
so they're just going through all the
different avengers right now
he did he died
what youtuber do i watch for intel
i don't watch any youtuber for
for intel i do my own endo
tuesday and by the way guys yes we do do
spoilers so if uh
if you don't want spoilers come back
after the episode's over in about 30
minutes and we'll talk
there's colton
and uh colton coulson
and uh
things are now changing because
black wood is under arrest because they
think she killed him
i'm counting on these not holding you
yeah rip f in the chat for tony stark
i'm alright
almost reminds me like the elevator
scene with steve
you mind holding this
[Laughter]
sure she can land a punch
but
[Laughter]
oh rumlow
drop crossbones you lost her
puente
antiguo
oh yeah regardless part
thunder's been happening a lot i will be
doing wait do you feel like you
personally get energy and drink do you
feel
uh yeah i do it's got a lot of caffeine
in it
and here comes thor oh
my ranking on first chiang chi is a nine
out of ten
nine point five out of ten i only have a
few qualms with it and i feel like if a
few fixed things or
one or two fixed things were slightly
altered it would have been a 10 out of
10.
um i already interviewed the director of
xiangxi i'm just editing it it should be
up
not tomorrow but the next day
thanks aaron vlog
creation male mid 20s
with really great hair
it's an accurate description sir he's
gorgeous
check this out
hold your fire i want to see this
spoiler's coming
olsen wasn't like coulson wasn't lying
about the hair
hold your fire
boom
i swear i didn't shoot
doesn't make any sense i don't slip i
don't miss fire
gorgeous fam thank you so much for the
super chat appreciate it
he'll talk to me
will he talk to you though
or is he dead
he dead
yep
you think he was murdered yeah because
he had wiping kids
[Laughter]
chippendales dancer
who's my f
he smells like lavender while rotting
yeah three three dead of the avengers
three dead of the avengers uh thor is
not a mortal
remember in the first avengers where
loki says the humans think us gods
should we test that theory
culver university of virginia look who
it is
dr ross
i know that chippendale's got me mr
anderson
it's not the vendors aren't really
becoming the suicide squad
i mean i guess so as in their dad
uh
what's up austin
no not love tyler her voice is very
distinct
don't worry liam's animation world you
get better
so here she is at the lab
dr ross here
trying to figure out
while wha what killed tony stark
episode three is out right now
um will we be able to watch live stream
tomorrow
if
it doesn't get taken down for copyright
which is why
which is why i'm not showing a lot of it
because it'll get taken down but she
just found out that clint died
uh what if there's nine or ten
like what a who do i kill
so pretty much he's saying that
he's taking taking this person is taking
out all the avengers that we're going to
be part of the avengers
move or i'll make you move what's up
bruce banner
uh no aquafina's character actually has
some pretty serious and important roles
in chongqing
the watcher watching over everybody
oh this part's so cool oh i forgot about
this part oh it's so cool
yes
uh mcu shows i think miss marvel and
hawkeye
yeah it came with bogeys
yes
this is so cool i love this part
and lady siff and the warriors three
kneel before god
i am loki
cell phone ringing you're gonna take
that
oh that would actually be cool richard b
to watch any game
like this
and here they come for the breeze banner
and ross
show off
vengeance
agent murdered thor
yeah bruce got hit
uh-oh bruce
thank you samuel kane appreciate that
oh okay looky looky
woohoo
problem liam hope you feel better
uh oh
that the black widow pose
there goes loki
hey mark thomas what's going on
yes malik it might be delayed i'm not
sure yet
loki in the meantime is
kind of kicking shields but
i don't know the next storyline for what
if i've only seen the first three
episodes
oh come on you think you were really
gonna
kill the hulk with a pistol
come on
uh-oh problems
problems for the hulk
that'd be a bad way to go
my favorite character from phase four
chongqi hands down
well he died so
hahaha
we have the same enemy the person who
killed your brother killed two of my
people we should work together
hey thanks tanzania i appreciate that
yeah savage isn't this a crazy episode
uh i would like live-action zombies i
think that would be pretty cool
awesome
here's something i'll address from pr
the shangchi's reviews aren't fake or
paid disney doesn't pay us to do
reviews
we get the
luxury of seeing things beforehand but
they don't pay us and i actually talked
to my rep the other day and he's like i
don't care if you don't like the movies
he's straight upset i don't care if you
don't like the movies you know it's
post your opinion
uh shanxi is one of my
probably top five favorite marvel movies
now i really liked it
thanks for run you
i'm excited for it too i'm excited to
make videos
here's black widow in a library though
she hears something
yeah you can still watch it tomorrow
liam
uh the other four
oh yeah so it's just i'll answer that in
a bit type in the chat again in a bit
what's up ron
you won't win
oh
i i wanna i wanna know if anybody can
figure out who the villain is who's
doing this to everybody
hey then
newbie pro official i would like to be
in a movie too a marvel movie too maybe
one day
natasha's gone now too
and now fury's just
pretty much alone
hustler man that would be pretty cool
chris is a cool dude
and your rockstars are awesome
i wrote the speech
i'm not the only avenger left and look
at this
captain marvel pager
yeah can y'all guess who's doing this
our last hope
hope all about him
either make a pact with a god or deal
with the devil
uh if i want to be in a marvel movie
what character do i want to play
wolverine
or
my own character
but
wolverine
look who it is
it's the destroyer
boom
i'm here to see your boss thursday some
of y'all are pretty close
so somebody all pretty close with your
guesses i haven't seen a right answer
yet in the chat
i kind of see a right answer in the chat
look hope van dyne
it's all about hope
spoilers coming
look
she died because shield killed her
agent hope van dyne
hank
hank
so look look what he did
he flew into him and killed him
he flicked hawkeye's wrist
he killed hawkeye
and put the expansion disc inside of
hulk
he's very powerful
and then he fought black widow
he smacked him
look at that
oh i forgot about this part it's really
cool it's like so cool
you're like wondering how furi's doing
all this crap right
so is hank
you're still pretty
so cool
it's so cool
you never cared about hope i don't give
a dang about any of them
smack
oh no he shot his daughter's grave
isn't that look it's so cool if you guys
figured it out now i figured it out by
this point
no he does not have the super soldier
serum he just has the help of somebody
so cool
yeah
isn't that cool
hello trickster guard trickster god
what up
then you honor her
then honor her
i thinking i might extend my stay
for how long friday
united nations new york city
and look who it is
the world has united under my command
look at all that so cool
you were made to be ruled
i've come to help you fulfill your
destiny
oh the avengers are dead
i like how they have their logos
look who it is
welcome back captain
captain marvel
and that's it
was that kind of cool
i never expected yellow jacket well i
never expected hank pym as yellow jacket
no there's not a post credit series i
want to see what the voices are though
no go back i want to see who the voices
are
i'm glad you like that episode infinity
shades i liked it too i didn't see it
coming it was a pretty big twist and it
was a pretty interesting idea like
what if okay cast
nick fury samuel jackson hank pym
yellowjacket
natasha romanov lake bell
tony stark mick wingert
clark gregg played ditch coulson frank
guerilla played brock rumlow jeremy
renner played hawkeye uh stephanie
penicello played betty ross not liv
tyler mark ruffalo played whole glowkey
was played by tom hiddleston general
ross mike mcgill i don't know what that
is jamie alexander played lady siff
alexandra daniels played captain marvel
interesting
interesting interesting interesting
that is the here i'll kind of expand
that for you guys
for those who want to see it
this is the
these are the voice actors and stuff
like that
so there we go all right well you know
what time it is it's time to get a
one make waves christopher
up in here where is my discord button
there it is
oh no he's going away
he went away what a nerd
all right
rate it
i've already seen one rating sci-fi
person eight out of ten what do you rate
this episode
oh
yeah wasn't it uh
wasn't it crazy it was definitely
different um
just different right like the avengers
died
the avengers died and it was hank pym
like that is that is something i didn't
expect i actually thought like it was
kind of the hulk fighting natasha in the
beginning or when natasha like died and
i was just kind of like
i don't understand but
when he said hope i was like oh i get it
it's gonna be it's gonna be hank because
she probably died or something yeah
oh chris is back
wudon's rank is meh
oh hi chris
oh your chair kept them entertained
yeah
i'm getting a lot of different ratings
for this episode
my deal
yeah my deal with what if is like
my excitement is stunted because it's
not real
just to be honest i think it's really
cool and i have fun watching it
but uh
if it
was live action and connected more to
the mcu and i yes i know that this is
supposed to be connected to the mcu but
if it was live action and a little bit
more i would uh i would honestly
be a lot more into it
just
to be perfectly honest i could be i
could be a lot more into it oh hold on
you're muted no you're muted
right now you're not muted now you're
not muted all right but that's what i
was gonna say like that's the big
problem for me it's like how much does
this really matter like it's cool it's
fun to watch
um i'm glad they kept them short because
if it was much longer i definitely
wouldn't be very interested at all
but yeah
yeah i do kind of enjoy that there's
shorter episodes oh they're all rating
it over here we got seven and a half
eight
the chair was pretty dope though
that's cool the chair was i love that
you still have rocket league open yeah i
have rocket league open what if i have
to play an emergency match real quick
with warren
yeah i wonder
hello john the animator you can stop
spamming now hello
um
i would have
i don't think the actor okay so
obviously the actor's gonna come back to
do voice-overs i don't think the actors
would have came to do a live-action
version of this at all
but there are i don't know there's some
cool things about this episode i like
how loki came
and basically used the excuse of his
dead brother to
conquer the world
and yeah and it worked this time right
it's coming from him who sent the
destroyer to kill him
in the actual mcu and then
it's funny because you see like the turn
of events you see how
since since thor
couldn't go back he couldn't come back
to save odin which put loki in charge
which mean loki stayed in charge which
mean he took over earth because thor was
yeah it is cool to see
how that stuff would play out because
it's fun to think about um
but again like
does it matter
you're right greg he didn't give me my
weekly check so i'm gonna speak my mind
it was awful real rejects what's up
everybody say hi to them sounds like
kevin feige didn't give you your weekly
check
no i've been pretty upfront about what
if i think it's uh
i think it's fun
i think it's a cool concept
but the lack
it just doesn't i'm not drawn in like i
am watching loki
because i'm like wow loki has like major
consequences not only for him as the
character who will continue to live on
in the mcu but the mcu in general so
yeah infinity shades thanks for super
chat again
i think it'd be a cool idea in that
universe
would be when cap comes out of the ice
now that thor is dead steve is worthy of
the hammer and what kind of comes out of
hiding with loki taking over the world
hey that would be cool you might have
actually be on to something there i
actually think that eventually there's
going to be
maybe in like episode 9 or 10
uh
like
the world's work will collide
i think if they built off of each other
would be more interesting too yeah and i
think i think that maybe like what they
are gonna do they're just trying to keep
it a secret at this point in time so
we'll see we'll see because they have
like a hyundai commercial or something
like some car commercial and it shows
like footage of them all fighting
together and i'm like is this like
actual footage like this is like
actually something that's gonna happen
there's the one episode we haven't seen
yet now that is um
where we get a different avengers and
that could be because all these avengers
are dead you know
yeah yeah yeah maybe that builds off
each other i was thinking more that
yeah i was thinking that was more like
an avengers of the galaxy type of thing
they seem more of a
cosmic avengers
i need a trademark
guardians of the galaxy
yeah
but without
the events playing up to it
it would be a different name
i guess so it's all a little weird it
leaves you wondering what if but uh
doesn't make you i'm not saying you're
begging for more of it right uh no and
there is gonna be a second season though
um
and it's gonna incorporate phase four
yeah so we'll see how the next
you know they haven't clarified so when
i was in the press conference for what
if
brad winterbomb
uh executive producer and he just
actually got promoted at marvel to
something i don't remember but he said
there was ten episodes but then collider
came out and said there were nine so i
don't i don't know how many episodes
and and then they got rid of one
oh maybe that's the case uh
but i don't know yeah
huh
well
icarus homelander
martian manhunter or captain marvel
well throw captain marvel out of there
she's not gonna win
um
i don't think martian manhunter would
win
um
i would say super man or homelander
i would say homelander you would say
homeland
he doesn't have the the kryptonite
weakness he doesn't have the kryptonite
weakness and he's freaking crazy have
any weakness and he'll do whatever the
heck he'll do
yeah don't worry homelander we can talk
this out
yeah i would say homelander would win
that probably i mean he killed milk
addiction but he kills
kids on planes right i mean yeah no
he'll kick he kills anything that moves
yeah
i'd say mr anderson says icarus
i i i don't know that much about it i
don't know his powers in the mcu
yeah so i don't know enough of my access
to make a fair a fair analysis on that
yeah i heard some interesting things
about i'm super excited to find out i
can't wait
i have theories about the eternals that
i want to turn into reality
so yeah no icarus is the superman of the
mcu though
um
so was like century and other characters
always meant to be in like the code
so for those of you like a lot of people
don't know who the eternals are because
their comic run like did crap i actually
never read their comics at all i had no
clue where they were a lot of people a
lot of people don't because their comic
runs did not last very long because they
weren't that successful
okay if i had to pick one dc character
to put in the mcu who would it be batman
i freaking love batman he's my he's my
favorite
uh but it also would be pretty cool
see wonder woman i don't know there's a
lot of cool people i would what about a
villain
what a villain would you take for the
avengers to fight a villain for the
avengers to fight
uh
i'm
i'm like
am i trying to scan through them all
real quick
yes but also like
because you you could get like
doomsday
uh dark side i mean there
and it's like those are kind of like
thanos
but i actually would like to see
like a joker
like a very non-powerful like a non
enhanced
villain
take on the avengers in like a very very
cynical calculated way
yeah that's something that the avengers
know actually ever go up against right i
would like like i would like him to i
would like to see the vendors go against
the joker and take them apart from like
with inside themselves right because the
joker will like threaten to kill a bunch
of people and stuff like that right and
they'd be like well avengers i'm gonna
do this
right and it would be like i'm gonna do
this and if you try to stop me i'm gonna
blow up a boat with a bunch of people on
it right and it's gonna have children on
it and stuff like that right i would
like to see that i would like to see
the avengers play essentially a chess
match with the joker yeah which isn't
really something you see ever in marvel
it's usually hey here's a bad guy with
an objective
and let's see if we can stop that object
objective yeah somebody like joker
doesn't really have an objective i want
something makes them so dangerous
well what i was going to say actually
hold on real fast car chef thanks for
another super chat heard that blue
marvel's supposed to show up with the
marvels i hope so because that would be
really cool but i i heard the rumor i
haven't heard anything confirmed thank
you for super chat i
i think
if there's one thing that marvel could
change
is have a villain
who is truly evil
just for the sake of being evil he's
evil he's just evil he's not like
i'm evil
but like you're also gonna feel sorry
for me eventually right like yeah yeah
you know what i mean like it's like loki
at the end of thor it's like
thor still like you're my brother
you know like what happens to marvel is
it's like somebody for like thanos for
example who has an idea that isn't
necessarily
wrong but the way they go about it is
right like loki wants to rule but he
does it in the worst way thanos wants to
balance the universe but he does it in
the worst way like this is all these
people and then the other half of the
time their enemies themselves civil war
or age of ultron they're fighting their
own mistakes well the chat makes a good
point zemo i i guess zemo did do that
he he tore apart the avengers
yeah and he did a fantastic job but i
have more things like that right but i
think
but still the same thing with zemo
he has he has the family that he lost
you know i mean he's like and i'm
strictly talking about the mcu at this
point right um right yeah yeah
ultron wasn't necessarily evil either he
he
he started right he had jar he started
off kind of as like jarvis blah blah
blah
and it was kind of like when he dug into
the internet in the world he saw the
world he was basically like oh this
sucks like you guys aren't good right so
here okay so i think here's the defining
point
all the villains think they're right
right i want a villain who knows he's
messed up and is just doing it to be
evil right like like zebo thinks he's
justified right ultron thinks he's
justified loki thinks he's justified i
want a thanos like i'm trying to save
the world i'm not evil it's just
efficient
right i want a villain that's just like
i just want to watch the world burn like
joker yeah like i just
some people just want to watch i'm
trying to watch the dark knight who's
going to watch the dark knight with me
yeah right oh walter gonzalez makes a
good point kang maybe yeah
kane could be yeah
this king in the mc is a little weird
yeah red skull
yeah
i just feel like he just wanted to be
powerful
yeah like
i because joker doesn't want to rule the
world he doesn't want any type of money
he literally just wants to destroy good
like he's a true psychopath he loves
chaos hello hello wanted to rule the
world right like there's everybody wants
something right the motives behind the
villain and i'm not crapping on the mcu
villains i'm just saying i would love to
see this right it's cool to see that
kind of chaos for the avengers uh
ego wanted to rule right he wanted yeah
he wanted everything to be him like
joker doesn't want to rule and i and i i
like that right um it's it's different
he's truly insane
like he's truly insane
so
king shark king shark wouldn't beat hulk
sorry
no
there's no chance hulk would would kill
king shark is durable but the hulk is
more durable and he packs a
uh i would you go home smash and and
shark nom nom and smash is winning
yeah i would say
20 20 king sharks at once honestly
probably oak really has untapped
potential we haven't even seen in the
mcu yet
i guess carnage
but that's but that's also
no no just villains but that's also
driven as a hatred towards venom
as well right and even venom
right and even venom is driven with a
hatred towards spider-man
or peter parker
because you know
so it's like there's always something
driving the evil
maybe mephisto
maybe mephisto because he's the devil
he's just evil
if he ever shows up
right now he's torturing us by not
showing up he's dr strange right now
just kidding
just kidding i'ma get it going again i
i don't believe he's dr strange i think
us as fans have turned mephisto in such
a meme
and hyped him up so much that now he's
definitely going to show up in the mcu
but marvel's going to time it just right
that it just has so much hype and
excitement right right now there's no
need reason we got no way home
multiverse minus all this excitement
it's like
now they know we'll go to the movies for
mephisto because of all the excitement
then they're going to time that right
yeah they're smart they know what
they're doing
they're gonna
yo
they do everything with purpose right
that's the thing about marvel is
i and i know people would disagree with
me but they're
the fan service comes from
marvel knowing their fans and knowing
what they'll like not from them going oh
the fans are telling us to do this so
let's do this
right they're kind of like knowing the
family above that right yeah yeah yeah
it's like not fan service it's different
than fan service it's fan justification
[Music]
i'll call it that
i don't know
i'm sure there are some villains in the
mcu right in our dark knight stream or
what yeah we're talking about
i honestly
hope we get
it from marvel too you know more of
these origin stories for villains like
joker or cruella for example like
they've all been really good
and they give a different light to these
villains it's really really cool
yeah yeah
um
no i i am joking i don't think um
i i don't think doctor strange is
mephisto i think he's
cocky arrogant dodge strange
because you gotta remember that's the
way he was before the like the cocky
doctor right and and now it's like oh
ancient one's gone
i was dead for five years
hopefully doctor strange multiverse of
madness kind of addresses where they
were when they were dead like were they
actually just
dead or
yeah i mean
some famous dude it very well could tie
in
somehow and they're saying it does
and maybe i'll care a little bit more
then don't get me wrong i like what if
i'm just not as like
as invested or like emotionally
connected to it as i would be like loki
or one division
so yeah it's not wrapping me and it's
interesting it's fun to watch i'm not
gonna be re-watching this one on hold
back yeah yeah alex franco it was pretty
cool to see yellow jacket
that's always cool
yeah i know i know so here's the thing
like i know they did say that they were
gonna connect but like how
like they're going to connect as in like
oh yeah that really did happen in a
different timeline in a different
universe somewhere it's like okay well
cool
really really doesn't change much for me
in all honesty and again don't get me
wrong i i like it
i'm just not
like the hype isn't the same right like
just the feeling for it isn't the same
but i do like it i enjoy watching it
it's pretty cool um
and i think i've said it multiple times
i'm not a big animation fan like
like
i always prefer live action and that's
just me but i do enjoy watching these
and they are cool the scenarios are cool
and there are cool parts and like
finding out that it was hank pym his
yellow jacket and wondering who it was
the whole entire time like that was fun
like i was like okay who is it who is it
who is it like that was fun it was fun
it's funny like
everybody says like oh i'm a disney show
and i always give everything such good
reviews and the second that i i'm like
it's all right yeah all right
you suck i'm not saying what do you mean
yeah that's pretty funny though
it is genuinely and chris can attest to
this it is genuinely hard for me to
actually really dislike something like a
movie no no yeah like walking out of
star wars and warren's there like it
wasn't that bad and i'm like what no
we're walking out of star wars the last
no
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
there like he's like in the bathroom
like yelling at him like it wasn't good
yeah
all right usually horn usually likes
those things do i ship looking silly
absolutely hell yeah we did since day
one absolutely i might do it
what's that
i was just saying we've been saying that
since the beginning like yeah absolutely
yeah but um
you know it's all in good fun and i
think that's the the real idea behind
what if teague over here is saying that
they're using what if to explain the
multiverse to people who don't
understand it and i think to some extent
that's true they're just trying to get
the multiverse out there but i think
also a lot of it's just a good way to
put content out there for for disney
plus to be honest and then you know it's
fun for us to sit there and watch and
you know we're here theorizing and all
of a sudden guess what we're talking
about dc villains who are going to be in
the mcu and that's all from what if you
know get the mind rolling they like to
see i think marvel likes to see what
fans come up with
and this is a good way of tapping into
that yeah i it's fun and it's different
which i think is really good for marvel
like it's it's good to do a different
thing i would say it is very refreshing
um refreshing for sure
and i will say
like shang chi is very refreshing
because it's different
because it's different wait change your
name
change your name from sean or shong to
sean
however declined you um
[Laughter]
wait what changed in this universe hope
joining shield no what changed in this
universe was all of the avengers died
well
i i don't think
they'd because because he you know hope
didn't die working for shield right
which is
different right so that there was
this universe was changed before that
right so the thing that triggered the
nexus event we'll call it was hope
joining shield and dying yeah i would
probably say so because that's what
would trigger her father to
kill
her
which was the highlight was that caused
all the avengers to die yeah because
they should have said like janet
because she got stuck in the quantum
realm you know so like so they could
have said like oh my wife right if you
yeah but
i i do think they'll bring them all
together some hey captain america still
alive somewhere yeah yeah yeah i i do
think
that they'll they'll bring them all
together in a different way
well maybe they re-arise as zombies i
don't who knows and that's where the
zombies come from it's because they died
in this episode i have no clue
some people have been asking
hold on
yes it's a one division poster
oh show them the points yes it is a loki
poster i have a and yes you can get them
black pink poster
oh no my camera fell hold on
uh
oh
and then i won't turn anymore
and there's a
wonder woman poster captain america
shield
and a black pink
poster behind me
and a twice poster behind me there we go
and there it is there's a slight
room tour
i know some people have been asking
about that
um
maybe i'll do one one day
um
we never know teak we never know feel
like spider-man will get hurt in battle
oh yeah i think he's gonna be over his
head and that's when the other spiderman
come in
he's going to get clapped
multiple times
oh that's a good point jeffrey chang
just realized cap shield has appeared in
each episode so far could it be an
ongoing trend for each upcoming episode
well wait probably why not it's fun to
draw it in
technically it wasn't cap shields in the
first episode
[Music]
well maybe they're somewhere maybe it
was theirs no i mean it's the same
shield right they just
painted it differently
uh do i think vulture and scorpion could
show up in no at home yeah no for sure
for sure for sure
we got those lego sets that confirmed
both of them theoretically yeah but they
said like based on far from home
no the ones i saw were literally said no
way home on them i don't know
i think literally has no way home logo
on it i think it would make sense for
mysterio vultures scorpion one of those
guys to be a villain because
there's no villains right now from them
from tom holland's universe
so i find it hard to believe mysterio
doesn't make a comeback quite frankly
yeah
thanks malek appreciate you watching
that um
when we get a hawkeye trailer
there was rumors that it could be this
month
or are we incept or at the emmys i think
when does when's the disney plus day
i don't know no but i do know
that
the emmys i think are next month which
people oh it could be in the emmys yeah
which people are saying that we might
get miss marvel and hawkeye
i don't know
liam your favorite marvel super is dr
strange my favorite marvel superhero is
thor
i think it's november 12th that's
probably too late right
uh it's definitely too late for hawkeye
if hawkeye's coming out in november
disney plus day is the 12th
yeah i'm thinking next month probably
for hawkeye
what's happening with miss marvel um
that is like
that's like a gray area right now they
haven't actually announced the release
for it yet so it's been pretty under
wraps too i'd say i haven't heard a
whole lot of books about it yeah i think
it's going to be a pretty impactful show
i think there's going to be some big
um repercussions and not even
repercussions but like effects of that
show that it's going to have um
tobin mcguire's in the chat what up
tell us
are you in the movie
just kidding just kidding i know you are
tell them though
tell them
uh what do i give this episode from one
to ten um
those are my least favorite out of the
first three really
i'd probably give it like a 6.5
7.
i'll give it a 7. i was genuinely
wondering who it was and when it was
hank pym i was actually pretty surprised
and i liked loki and i liked the loki
scene at the end i think the second
episode has been my favorite so far
for sure so
uh yeah but hope you guys enjoyed the
episode i have to wake up early because
i have more chongqi interviews tomorrow
i am
interviewing falachan who is the mother
of shang chi in the movie and that's
early in the morning so i gotta pass out
uh how would i rate each avengers death
i'll answer that real quick um
uh
i don't like tony starks
it was all right i mean they're all
clever
yeah but as far as on screen
deaths i think black widow had the best
off
your camera just die
no i turn it off i'm switching over if
you want to send people this i'll stay
on a little longer have you ever thought
of doing k-pop related vids or k-pop
channel because i would subscribe
immediately i have oh my gosh guys
that's the question warren wanted to
hear oh i could talk so long about that
um
something coming to the future new year
and i record yeah
maybe
i haven't
i i'm going to do
a a channel where i do covers of music
there it is
but i don't know how to encourage him i
don't know how much that'll be a k-pop
related channel i will sing k-pop
but like
well i do k-pop updates and stuff like
that probably not maybe reactions to the
music the stray kids album came out
that's an amazing album it's really
really great it's really good it's
really good
i love k-pop by default because of how
much they hang out with warren it's true
it's like all i listen to thank you for
that uh
super chat that's a good question
so all right guys i gotta wait once i
got one more question from a new member
so let's answer a question for both of
you if the other spiderman get pulled
into no way home theoretically at one
point in the movie would you like to see
them get pulled from wait sorry say that
again
if if the other spiderman theoretically
get pulled into the spiderman movie at
what point in their movies would you
like to see them get pulled from so
where in their movies from their
universe do you want to see them get
pulled the the end
the end of each thing that we saw yeah
straight out yeah yeah i want them fully
experienced to be able to help our peter
parker yeah i like that
i want them to be his father figures
yeah and i want them to say with great
power i want toby to say with great
power comes great responsibility i
really i i'm living for that right now
but
but all right guys i gotta take off i
gotta get some sleep so i don't look
like
death in the morning in my interview but
thank you all so much for joining thanks
for everybody who chatted uh thanks for
everybody who super chatted thank you to
mr anderson for being a great mod uh
thank you to everybody who just sat in
the background and watched because they
enjoyed it appreciate you all
love you all i will see you here next
week uh everybody say good night
bye uh my breakdown is gonna come
probably later tomorrow um
i have a spiderman vid coming out in the
morning and then
once i get done with the interview and
everything i'll start working on the
breakdown for what if i have to uh
i have to go to bed now otherwise i do
right now so but alright guys
i will see you next time woof